hello okay who set this up
who set up seed burn calling no way you
saw Facebook one but you don't know
you're on the podcast right now no
really because I didn't here's the thing
today they had set up a bunch of people
calling in and so right now I'm on the
podcast and people are calling it no no
it's great this is great there's a great
surprise guest this is not this is not a
part of the plan then thank you so much
as Steve Moore burned if you guys don't
know he's a comic he's half Korean very
handsome very talented guy he just did a
movie starring Jimmy O yang right and
Steve Byrne and what was it what's the
movie called oh man it was just good
working with you that's all it's good
working with you I'm kidding dude I I
really do I know the movies gonna be
great
how does it look can I just see this
before my fans and whatnot is that Steve
Byrne you've always had my back
when that whole ken Jeong thing happened
in at carbs and he physically attacked
me you you're the one remember you're
the one that separated us you're the one
that calmed everything down you're the
one that flew me out there just to even
try to do the [ __ ] thing and you've
always have my back and I really
appreciate it I love you alright watch
opening act goodnight goodnight a team
bye-bye
it was deeper was it that was back he's
part of it none of us what do you mean
one of us one of us okay one of us
that's him music locks t burn you'll
never know anymore enjoy enjoy the
attention for the day because what he
called him like oh here's a war when's
the last time he ever called no your
birthday today I know but I'm just
saying it's like in my head is like oh
here's a war that's about to happen
yeah but you love him I do love him and
he loves you he loves to live the
keymaster yeah but you know the honest
[Music]